what's up guys welcome to ij likes i am
at the top of diamond head right now in
the process to actually film this video
it took way too much time so i hope that
you enjoy our fantastic location let's
start the show
it's been a really busy week we swam
with sharks this week
look for that video soon but some of my
favorite videos this week
one of which i'm sure all of you little
monsters are quite aware of
gaga applause
jenna maybe applause
thank you
[Music]
this is going to be a lot harder than i
thought but anyway here's the video that
she released
[Music]
let me know what you guys think of it in
the comments below and our next video oh
this plane just sucks man i'm gonna be
able to finish this this is absolutely
amazing a bunch of you guys
[Music]
you guys tweeted it to me it's shark
nato cupcakes now i'm absolutely
obsessed
[Music]
here are sharknado cupcakes they turned
out so cute
[Music]
so on the tour like they they show you
all the different like famous places
where things are filmed next up is tech
and gaming this week is gamescom so
there is so much going on in germany and
i'm obviously not in germany but i am
swimming with sharks so
[Music]
this is amazing
gta online released some gameplay i'm
really excited to waste away my life in
yet another online multiplayer game and
not really do anything in my real life
it's great gta online is set to launch
two weeks after gta 5. also in the same
realm of a game saints row 4 is out as
you guys know i'm absolutely obsessed
with this game because i really just
like to get in my vehicle
and run people over
and moving right along because this is
really hard to shoot here
style and fashion oh
hold up wait a minute let me put you up
back into it is that what how that sound
goes obviously
i knew everything about style and
fashion judging by what i'm wearing
right now i've got on this
fabulous fanny pack
although we did find this really cool
jewelry designer named i don't know how
to pronounce it do you know how to
pronounce this chad i have no clue what
this is called mia
m-i-a-n-s-a-i we got these cute little
bracelets these anchor bracelets
also
fashion did you see joey's outfit at the
one direction premiere fashion can we
talk about how freaking cute i want to
be like who are you wearing oh my god
joey tell me who are you wearing maybe i
can get joey to submit me a clip and
tell me who he's wearing probably can
shoot thanks girl um pretty much my
blazer was from a store called topman
which is my absolute favorite uh my
shirt and tie were from a store called
emmett and pants and shoes were from
asos and there you have it
thanks everybody who has been doing the
hashtag ij book club if you guys don't
know you can get a free book at
audible.com ijustine this week i
downloaded the steve jobs book because i
already read it but i want it to be read
to me and jenna actually downloaded her
free book would you get i did i
downloaded the orange is the new black i
don't even know what that is i just
watched it on netflix and then i thought
it was a book so i was like please tell
me more read it to me please hear me
okay bye
yeah let me know what book you guys get
audible.com i just seen you could sign
it with amazon which is amazing because
i buy toilet paper toothpaste i i buy
basically everything i bought this case
on amazon i didn't buy this fanny pack
on amazon though
i'll see you guys later thank you so
much for watching don't forget to
subscribe hit me up on all of the
instagrams and twitters and vines and
whatever else i'm gonna leave because
this video was actually so hard to shoot
i'll show you guys some outtakes here
bye relax
it's going to be okay
no you're not going down without us
we're right here it's right there that
spot right there that's the top right at
the very very top how can they not like
appreciate this it's gorgeous
you want to walk upstairs no come on
just carry them you can do it i just
carried them all
i cannot even see if i'm even in frame
yeah okay